JOHN POLLACK: Thank you
all for having me.
I'm a big fan of Google.
I use your products
every day--
seven days a week.
I love the Ngram Viewer.
As a researcher, it's
tremendous.
So is there anybody here
who worked on that?
All right, well, whoever,
among your
colleagues, did fantastic.
So I just want to say
that I don't take
what you do for granted.
I mean, I think if you grow up
at a certain age, pre-Google,
pre-web, you take research
a little bit for granted.
And so I got started as a
reporter 25 years ago at the
Hartford Courant.
And you had to track everyone
down by telephone.
And so you'd call somebody and
they'd tell you, no, I'm not
the person.
You need to talk to so and so.
And you'd find that number.
It was a process of looking
up numbers in phone books.
And we used to, in the bureau
where I worked in New Britain,
Connecticut--
I covered the sewer
commission, among other things--
we had all these phone books
so you could track down
people, and even out of date
phone books because people
would de-list their numbers
because they didn't want to
get called by reporters.
And so phone books were
our best friends.
And I did this story once on
phone books and the history of
the Yellow Pages.
Do you know why the Yellow
Pages are yellow?
Well, as it turns out, in 1883,
in Cheyenne, Wyoming,
there was a printer and he was
printing up something new
called the phone book, the phone
directory, and he ran
out of white paper.
And rather than wait for the
next train, he said, I'll just
print it on what I have,
which was yellow.
And it caught on and we
have the Yellow Pages.
And so ever since, we've let
our fingers do the walking.
Except now, thanks to
you, we do it on a
computer using Google.
So apart from the Ngram Viewer,
which I love, there's
a couple other features that
really appeal to me.
And one is Google Doodles.
And there's one on the
back wall, and there.
I see them all the time.
I love Google Doodles because we
live in this era where the
corporate brand police at most
companies guard their logos
like Fort Knox.
And Google plays with
it constantly.
And in the process, is asks the
viewer to make sense of
it, to pull out the meaning,
to search.
And I love how the use of the
logo engages people in the
very product that you sell,
which is the ability to search
for meaning.
The second feature that I
love is the autofill.
So on the autofill function,
I'm typing one letter.
I haven't even decided what I'm
searching for exactly, and
it starts guessing ahead.
And I think it's like a game.
Sometimes I stop to check to
see if it was before I do
what's happening.
And the ability to intuit an
answer from incomplete or
conflicting information is
exactly what we do as people
when we listen to people and
when we talk to people.
As I'm speaking now, the
research shows that you're
accepting these sound waves and
processing them and trying
to guess ahead how I'm going
to finish the word, how I'm
going to finish the sentence,
what I mean.
And even if you have to double
back at the end because you
guessed wrong, it's worth it
from a biological standpoint,
because it speeds up
conversation and human exchange.
So this happens to be the crux
of punning, too, at its core--
trying to decide, based on
conflicting information or
incomplete information,
incomplete context, what does
somebody mean?
And so who knew that Google
was a punning organization
intrinsically?
So that's what I love when
I get to work on Google.
So what is a pun?
Any definitions from
the audience?
Anybody want to hazard
a guess?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Using words in a way
that could be interpreted two
different ways.
JOHN POLLACK: Exactly.
Now, that's the core
definition.
That's what I use.
They come in a lot of
different forms.
That's the beautiful thing about
punning, is that as soon
as you try and define it,
somebody can come up with one
that is slightly different.
But you hit the nail
on the head.
And so what do the people in
this room think about puns?
I take it it's a
self-selecting audience, right?
Raise your hands if
you like puns.
Let's have a show of hands.
All right, anybody?
There's one person with their
hand down, but OK.
Fair enough.
In general, in society, what's
the take on puns?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Lowest
form of humor.
JOHN POLLACK: Lowest
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: People groan.
JOHN POLLACK: Groan, juvenile,
you name it, the pun gets
kicked around.
And the truth of the matter
is that, for most of human
history, the pun was a sign of
intelligence, of wit, of
insight, of wisdom.
And it wasn't always intended
as humorous.
It was just a way of encoding
more meaning in fewer words.
But in the last 400 years
or so, it had
this fall from grace.
And so what I want to talk about
today is how it fell
from grace, why we're living
in a pun Renaissance today,
because the pun is making a
huge come back, and then I
want to share with you how the
pun enabled the rise of modern
civilization.
Now, you laugh.
I'm serious about this.
And by the end of it, I think
you'll come away with a new
appreciation of an art
form that you all
practice every day.
So let's start out by taking
a look at when puns were at
their apex in English, roughly
400 years ago.
English as a language
was in major flux.
In the couple centuries earlier,
in the 1300s, the
plague had come to England and
it had killed off a third of
the population--
a million people.
And that just drove
major disruption.
And people started fleeing
their villages.
So you started to have a mixing
of regional accents and
a mixing of regional dialects.
And English was already a
real mutt of a language.
I mean, the Romans had brought
Latin, you had Celtic grammar,
you had Anglo-Saxon
vocabulary.
The Vikings had invaded.
They gave us words like
knot and haggle.
Good words.
Who knew they were Viking?
And then you had the
Norman invasion.
And then you had 10,000 French
words come into English--
decolletage, debonair,
double entendre--
good one.
And so English was a swirl.
And what happened was in the
age of Shakespeare, in the
late 1500s, early 1600s, puns
were just hugely popular.
Lawyers punned, judges punned
in their judgments, the
playwrights were punning,
the poets were punning.
Even condemned criminals would
pun on the gallows to show
that, hey, I'm not so low.
I still have eloquence, I still
have wit, I am a worthy
human being.
And so puns were
in power then.
So what happened?
How did we go from puns at their
apex, extremely popular,
to puns being kicked to the curb
as low humor, juvenile,
lowest form of wit?
OK.
There were several factors.
The first was the arrival
of the printing press.
So technology can
always disrupt.
The first printing press came
to England in 1476.
And what happens when
you print something?
You have to choose a spelling.
And when you choose a spelling,
you favor a meaning.
So as you shift from an oral
culture to a print culture,
suddenly some of the wind is
lost from the sails of punning
because punning thrives
on ambiguity.
And that's why I always feel
that spoken puns are better
than written puns because they
preserve the surprise a little
bit longer.
A second factor was
the rise of the
turnpike system in England.
As better road spidered out
from London, the accents,
which had been kind of a mix of
all these regional accents,
gave way to kind of the cultural
dominance of London.
And so the London accent became
the norm, the standard
by which others were judged.
And so you started to suck out
some of the diversity in the
language and differences in
pronunciations that fueled puns.
And then the next thing that
happened was coffee.
Now, you think, what
does coffee
have to do with punning?
In 1632, I believe it was,
the first coffee
house came to London.
And this was pre-tea--
England before tea.
And so these coffee houses
became a great mixing pot of
social classes, and a lot of
fierce debate, and different
ideas clashing.
And they were great sources
of punning.
And if you look at the big
names of the day, you had
Nicholas Rowe, John Dryden,
Jonathan Swift--
all these famous writers all
going back and forth at each
other every day in
the coffee shops.
But a funny thing happened was
that in this mixing of
classes, the aristocrats
realized that, hey, they
weren't that much smarter than
the average Joe when it came
to punning.
And some of the social status
that had been associated with
punning was suddenly called into
question, because, well,
hey, if everyone can pun, it
must not be that great a mark
of distinction.
And so class became a factor.
The other thing that happened
was that people like Sir Issac
Newton started gathering, and
scientists started talking.
And this was the birth
of the Enlightenment.
And so there was a rise in the
importance of reason--
of scientific law, of logic.
Puns are very unruly
by their nature.
They jump fences of meaning,
they don't seemed
to belong to order.
They're very subversive.
And so as the Enlightenment
took root, the
status of puns fell.
They were suspect.
And so what playwrights had been
using to hold attention,
to undermine the royal censors
through double meanings
started to fall in status.
And so the pun started
its slide down.
And then along came
Samuel Johnson.
Does anybody know
Samuel Johnson?
OK.
Yeah.
He wrote the first real
English Dictionary.
And the thing was is that
English had sort of been a
second-tier language.
But when he wrote the
dictionary, it was an attempt
to kind of put English on the
map, to fix meanings.
And he started out in
the late 1740s.
To do this, he raised money for
the project as a startup,
and he locked himself in
this garret in London.
You can visit it.
It's a great little
garret to visit.
And he thought he'd done
in two years or so.
Two years became three, three
years became four.
He ran out of money.
There are bars on the windows
above the door there because
people were trying to break in
to steal stuff to collect
their debts from him.
That's how bad it got.
And after nine years of slaving
away in this garret,
in 1755, he came out with
the dictionary.
And it made him a celebrity.
He was a rock star of the age.
And, of course, if you spent
nine years going crazy and
going broke writing a
dictionary, what do you
dislike most?
Double, triple meanings.
So he hated puns--
hate them.
And he used his bully pulpit
to denigrate them.
In fact, he later came out
with a collected works of
Shakespeare, and he started
taking out the puns.
And he said, Shakespeare
would--
I'm paraphrasing--
Shakespeare would be pretty good
if he weren't so willing
to sacrifice everything
for a pun.
And, of course, Johnson did a
great service to English by
writing the dictionary, but he
did a great disservice by
dissing puns.
But even he couldn't
resist a good one.
So there's a great story.
I was researching the book
and came across this--
in the rare book room
at the public
library on 42nd Street--
there was this little
leather-bound volume of
collected puns from 1826.
And I was flipping through it.
And I came across the story
about Samuel Johnson punning.
And I thought, that bastard,
I've got him.
And so here's the story.
He's walking through London
one day with Boswell, his
assistant and later biographer,
and they're
passing Old Bailey,
the courts.
And there's a crowd gathering.
And he says, Boswell, go find
out what's happening.
So Boswell comes back
and says, there's
going to be a hanging.
He says, we'll, find
out who it is.
So he goes and it turns out
that the guy being hung--
the condemned man's
name is Mr. Vowel.
And Johnson turns to Boswell
and says, Bosie, well, it's
very clear that it's neither
you nor I. See, clearly, he
had no problem with capital
punishment.
So, listen.
Despite Johnson's effort, the
pun survived, and England is a
very pun-rich culture.
But here in America, even as
the English were kind of
rejecting it, we were saying
we were embracing it.
And the early colonial preachers
punned from the
pulpit, here, to keep
people engaged.
And, in fact, if you do an
image search, you'll find
great punning sign boards across
America today in that
same tradition.
So one I loved was God
answers knee-mail.
K-N-E-E. God answer
an knee-mail.
There was another one--
the sun cures sinburn.
And you'll appreciate
this one.
It's not a pun, but it says,
there are some questions
Google can't answer.
Anyway.
You might doubt that.
So the early political leaders
of this country,
too, were big punsters.
And I was doing some research
and came across a great letter
from Thomas Jefferson to
Abigail Adams at the
Constitutional Convention
in 1789.
And I'll get the exact quote,
but he basically said, listen,
you wouldn't believe all the
punning that's going on here.
And he said, the people at large
view every object only
as it may furnish
puns in bon mot.
And I pronounce that a good
punster would disarm the whole
nation where they ever
disposed to revolt.
So the great orators, the great
statesman, the great
writers of the era, they
were punning too.
And it was happening
on all levels.
So out on the frontier in the
1830s, Davy Crockett was a big
punster and a bragger.
And he was a celebrity in
his day, even before
he died at the Alamo.
And there was a riddle going
around in the early 1830s--
how many years does Davy
Crockett have?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN POLLACK: Three--
a left ear, a right ear,
and a wild frontier.
So what happened?
So how did we go from puns being
popular to low status?
Well, in the early 20th century,
all the Jewish
comedians on Vaudeville
celebrated the pun--
Henny Youngman, the Marx
Brothers, George
Burns, Gracie Allen.
Punning was a big thing.
And then after World War II,
there was a shift in humor
just as there was a
shift in music.
As jazz became less structured,
as art became more
abstract, humor migrated away
from set piece jokes and into
more the Woody Allen, Lenny
Bruce free-flowing
dysfunctional narrative
sort of humor.
And puns were left high and
dry, as old fashioned.
And you still got smart punning
in some pop culture.
Think of "MASH" and
Hawkeye Pierce--
Alan Alda as Hawkeye Pierce.
Just brilliant punning back
and forth, back and forth,
again, for purposes
of subversion.
But in general, the pun
was on the decline.
And that's when you had
the groans set in.
So just a question here.
What does the groan mean?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: It means
you got the joke.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it means you get
it, but you kind of want
to pretend you don't like it.
JOHN POLLACK: Exactly.
Or, it could mean, I didn't
get it, but I don't
want to admit it.
Or it could mean it was
brilliant, but I don't want to
encourage you.
Or it could mean I thought
it was awful.
Or it could mean that your brain
is toggling between so
many different emotions so
quickly that that's what comes
out because you just don't
know what to say.
And so the groan as a cultural
reflex is a post-war cultural
reflex, just as the rim
shot set in there too.
Badump-bump.
Now, originally that came out
of Vaudeville, and it was an
affirmation that, hey,
good job, good joke.
Nice work.
And then after, it was
associated with,
oh, that was cheesy.
So I don't want you to think,
though, that the idea that
puns are cheesy or low or
juvenile or unpopular is true,
because that's actually
not the case.
Because let's look at
the marketplace.
Puns sell.
Who can think of some punning
product names?
OK.
Let's just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN POLLACK: What's that?
It was a toilet bowl cleaner.
JOHN POLLACK: OK, great.
What about Cherry Garcia,
flavored ice
cream, or Carmel Sutra--
the whole Ben and
Jerry's line.
How about the name of your
company, based on a pun.
How about--
let's see.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN POLLACK: Yeah.
Or Verizon.
The name Verizon is a
portmanteau of very true and
horizon, true horizon.
Try getting reception--
not always true.
What about when you get your
iPhone, there's a little
booklet that comes with it
called "Fingertips." And if
Apple's doing puns, that's not
very Apple-like, but they
can't resist, because
it's cool.
So who here eats
Chipotle ever?
Anybody ever eat at Chipotle?
OK, so a couple years ago,
they had this brilliant
campaign, and it was celebrating
their, I think,
17th anniversary or something
like that.
And they were celebrating the
quality of their ingredients.
And to do so, they were
wrapping their
burritos in gold foil.
And their campaign
was ausome--
A-U-S-O-M-E--
from the gold in the
periodic table.
And it speaks to the
intelligence of both the
people on the selling end,
but the intelligence and
expectation of intelligence on
the receiving end as well.
All the movies.
Think about "Gnomeo and Juliet"
or "Ratatouille." Did
anybody see "Ratatouille,"
about the
rat, the chef in Paris?
I mean, it's brilliant.
And so the reason why people
pun in these situations is
that puns sell.
There was this Dutch study that
showed that consumers
preferred slogans that
included puns--
the more meanings the better--
even when they completely
imagined that there was a pun.
So there didn't even have
to be a pun, and
they liked that better.
Think about the way that puns
creep into our language.
Did anybody here have
branch last weekend?
Some people probably did.
Branch--
breakfast and lunch.
Smog--
smoke and fog.
Medicare, Obamacare.
Look at all the tabloid
newspapers.
The headlines each day here in
New York-- the Post and the
Daily News go at it trying
to out-pun each other.
Because puns sell.
Now, why is this?
Well, part of the reason is that
we're so bombarded with
information all day
every day--
ads projected on the sidewalk,
blinking lights, laser beams
popping-- everyone's trying to
get our attention, saying,
hey, look at me, hey,
look at me.
And part of the challenge
is just
capturing people's attention.
And puns are sticky, because
they pack more meaning into
fewer words, and so they're
very sticky.
And that's why puns
work so well.
Now.
I don't want you to think that
puns are just light, because
they're not.
In the course of the book, I
interviewed an anthropologist
about the significance of puns,
and he had studied these
long pun duals in Tzotzil, which
is a Mayan dialect in
the Chiapas Highlands
of Mexico.
And they have these long ritual
punning duals in which
they go back and forth, back and
forth for hours, and you
lose face if you lose it.
But they use these pun duals to
communicate ideas that are
sensitive or perhaps taboo.
Like, hey, I'd like to
marry your sister.
And so they might
seek permission
through these pun duals.
It's called [INAUDIBLE]--
I'm probably mispronouncing
the Tzotzil.
But that's the form.
And again, I mentioned a few
moments ago about the
Shakespearean playwrights would
use puns to evade the
royal censors.
Well today, in China, the
censors are going wild trying
to police all the puns because
while you can control what
someone says, you cannot control
what someone means and
what people infer.
and so a good punster is the
censor's worst enemy.
There's a video on YouTube
called "The Ballad of the
Grass Mudhorse." And it's an
entirely satirical punning
story of a unicorn-like creature
who's defeating the
river crabs.
But all the names of the
creatures are punning
references to things that
are banned in China.
And they're sticking a finger
in the eye of censors.
So if you go back to George
Orwell's "1984," there's a
postscript on there about
newspeak, the language that
the government was working
on that would
eliminate double meanings.
And he said that it would take
a while, but by 2050 it would
be complete, and that if you
could eliminate double
meanings and only have approved
words, no one could
even think a subversive
thought.
And I think it's a testament
that he thought that
totalitarianism would come in
1984, but language would
allude control for much,
much longer than that.
So punning is very powerful,
even today.
And we're really living
in a pun Renaissance--
not just in the market.
But for anybody who's
interested, there's a contest
called Punderdome 3000.
Has anybody been to that?
Yeah.
A couple people.
It was last night in Brooklyn.
It's once a month at
Little Fields.
It's a great show.
But there were 350 super nerds
in the room punning--
not everyone was punning.
But it was just electric.
And we're really living in
a renaissance of the pun.
So we're lucky for that.
So I want to talk to you briefly
about one more main
idea, and then I'm going
to take questions.
And this is getting back to what
I said earlier that the
pun enabled the rise of
modern civilization.
So how old do you think the
first evidence of punning is?
Any takers on that one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN POLLACK: By
a factor of 10.
So about 35,000 years
ago, we have our
first evidence of punning.
Now, how do we know that?
You might say, oh, there's
no recordings,
there's no written language.
But what we do see are these
carved stone statues about the
size of an Oscar.
And on one side it's a naked
woman, and if you rotate it
180 degrees, it's an
erect phallus.
And what it shows is that people
have the capacity to
see two ideas they
were different--
they were inseparable,
but different.
And what you saw depended on
angle that you looked at it.
So we know that people had
the capacity for punning
35,000 years ago.
Now think of the challenges
of language.
So if you had, say, you were in
the cave and you wanted to
paint a picture that said,
great buffalo hunt today.
We killed three buffalo.
OK, easy enough, right?
You light your torch, you get
your pigments, and you paint
three buffalo on the wall, and
you put in three spears or
three arrows, and boom,
you're done.
OK.
Great.
All right.
Now let's say you flash forward
to ancient Mesopotamia
and you want a contract because
you're sending 478
sheep to Ur on Saturday for this
price, and here are the
payment terms.
And it's a lot more complicated,
and it's a lot
harder to do with
just pictures.
I mean, pictures are great for
nouns, OK for simple verbs,
but for the complexity of law,
for the complexity of tense,
for anything subjective, it's
very, very difficult.
So what the scribes started
doing is they needed
abstractions, they needed
relational words.
And they had this intellectual
breakthrough in both Egypt and
Mesopotamia--
about the same time--
where they said, gosh, this
hieroglyph, this cuneiform
script, it sounds like x, or
part of it sounds like x.
And they'd break off that piece
and they'd just harvest
the phonetic value for
other purposes.
So, in essence, they
were punning.
So knock knock.
AUDIENCE: Who's there?
JOHN POLLACK: Isabel.
AUDIENCE: Isabel who?
JOHN POLLACK: Isabel necessary
on a bicycle?
All right.
OK, so you think stupid
knock-knock joke.
But it's actually a very
complicated intellectual
process to take those phonetic
chunks and re-purpose them
into an entirely new context
and meaning.
And that's what the scribes
in Egypt and
Mesopotamia were doing--
not knock-knock jokes, per se,
but they were using the same
process of breaking apart sound,
symbol, and meaning and
recombining.
Now, you might think, oh, who
is John Pollack to assert
this, and I actually went and
I interviewed Richard
Parkinson, who is the
Head Egyptologist
at the British Museum.
He's also an excellent
punster, by the way.
And he said, oh, of course, and
he started pointing out
all of the puns in the ancient
Egyptian hieroglyphs.
And not all of them were meant
as funny, but they ran
throughout the hieroglyphs, and
the ancient Egyptians were
big time punsters
on many levels.
And it wasn't all about humor,
it was about religion, it was
about deeper meaning, it
was about identity.
And so if you look at the
ancient hieroglyphs, as the
evolved into script, you started
seeing some symbol for
symbol noun-like meaning, and
you also saw phonetics coming
into play, where symbols had
strictly phonetic values.
And in about 1700 BC, scribes
unknown and in the sign they
had this brilliant breakthrough,
and they said,
screw all the one for
one symbology.
Let's just go for a straight
phonetic alphabet.
And that's what they did.
And they came up with the
North Semitic alphabet.
And that became the basis for
Phoenician, for Greek, for
Russian, for Persian,
for Sanskrit,
for the English alphabet.
It was incredibly liberating,
because suddenly you had this
way to write down ideas of
infinite complexity---
anything.
You could write about
You didn't have to carve
or paint all
these complicated symbols.
You could just, boom, do it
really efficiently and you
could transmit that information
over time.
So once you could transmit ideas
of infinite complexity
over time, you had this rapid
acceleration in the
accumulation of knowledge.
And so suddenly the progress
of civilization
started taking off.
So, in essence, if you had no
puns, no punsters, you would
have had no phonetic
alphabet--
no phonetic alphabet, no
practical way of writing.
No practical way of writing--
no way of transmitting knowledge
over time, and we
wouldn't be sitting here in a
tall building in New York City
in a modern civilization.
No puns no, modern
civilization.
Does that make sense?
Great.
So there are always going to
be critics of the pun.
And there are some people that
will deny that the pun matters
or that the pun played
this catalytic role.
And I would say that a lot of
that's because they feel
somehow threatened by the pun.
Because the pun fogs up the lens
of clarity through which
they like to view the world and
impose order, or at least
the illusion of order.
Because when people denigrate
puns, they're denigrating one
of the great creative catalysts
in history.
And I say this because puns
really sharpen our creative
thinking skills.
The great thing about punning
is that it takes you from
topic A to topic Q very
randomly sometimes,
apparently.
And you're making an assertion
that there is a connection.
And that is the essence
of creativity.
It's trying out new
associations, it's trying to
find connections between
disparate topics.
And I would argue that the pun
is humanity's first hyperlink.
Let's go from A to Q or to P--
whatever.
And it's this power of
association that let us go
from cave to hut to castle to
skyscraper to space station.
It's a series of very wild and
unlikely associations that
accumulate over time, and this
willingness to take risks that
is this ability to see
connections and meaning.
That's what fuels
human progress.
And so when you think
about two people
banging rocks together--
somebody said, wow, that
causes a spark.
And then they light a fire.
And then suddenly you're
boiling water
and generating steam.
And someone says, oh, we can
generate electricity, and then
pretty soon we're talking
on our iPhones.
And all of that sweep of
history, all of it, comes
through these really amazing
unlikely associations through
human creativity.
And that is one side of
the coin, and punning
is the other side.
It's the same exact process.
Now, am I arguing that punning
is a substitute for reason?
No.
I'm not.
But neither is reason a
substitute for imagination.
And it's the willingness to
imagine that gives us a
destination that we can aim at
and pursue through reason.
But were it not for the
imagination, we'd be sunk.
And in this era of great
challenges, great global
challenges, imagination and
innovation are more
important than ever.
So I would just say pun with
pride and remember that your
wordplay is always more
than semantics.
Thank you.
Any questions from anybody?
Comments?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was reading a book by Joel
Spolsky recently, and he said
that there's no place for puns
in software, especially user
interfaces where we're trying
to accommodate people who
might not know your language
as their first language.
They might be reading it in
a different language.
What are your thoughts on the
place of puns in software?
JOHN POLLACK: Well, I confess
that I fall into the category
of I like to click the
button yes or no.
So I'm not an expert at software
by any stretch.
I would say that punning is
very relevant meaning.
And if you're writing software
or writing language, you are
using those as a tool
to communicate.
And in law, you're trying to,
sometimes, eliminate the
possibility for confusion, or
you're trying to allow for
some gray area, some wiggle
room down the line, in a
contractor, per se.
And so I think punsters would
have a great advantage in
writing software, because you
would be able to see the
possibilities.
And listen.
Code is a creative process,
and coding
is a creative process.
And so it's important to have
a spirit of play and
elasticity.
If you didn't, it wouldn't
be any fun.
Because there's elegance
in it.
And sometimes there's
elegance in a pun.
So I don't know if
that answers your
question, but, yes.
AUDIENCE: So regarding your
time in Spain being the
Foreign Correspondent, did you
find that punning was similar
in Spanish media and also in the
Spanish language compared
to English?
And if not, then what were some
of the differences in the
way that they use the pun?
JOHN POLLACK: With all due
credit to my high school
Spanish teacher, Mr. Puente, I
wasn't great at Spanish when I
arrived in Spain, although
I had a good
grasp of the grammar.
I do recall that when I finally
made a pun in Spanish,
which was like two years down
the line, I felt I am somehow
achieve cultural fluency,
even though it was a
poor version of it.
Any language, Spanish included,
that has a tradition
of literature--
has puns in it and tends
to celebrate puns--
I couldn't comment specifically
on puns in
Spanish headlines, because I've
been reading them for a
long time, but my guess is
they're there, as well,
because they are throughout
Spanish literature.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Actually kind of
a follow-up to that.
Do you think that the notion
of the pun being the lowest
form of humor is like an
American cultural thing?
And have you noticed any
differences around the world
and how they're perceived?
JOHN POLLACK: Well, certain
cultures, as I mentioned,
esteem punning.
And, as I mentioned, in the
Tzotzil speakers of the
Chiapas Highlands,
it's high honor.
One of the interesting things
that I use the Ngram viewer
for, which lets you search
for phrases over time
in millions of books--
it actually came out after I
had finished my research on
"The Pun Also Rises" and I had
been trying to figure out,
pardon the pun, no pun intended,
when did these
phrases come into use?
Because then you could track of
the denigration of the pun,
the fall from grace.
And I was relieved that I was
within 10 years, through old
fashioned bookwork, to
the Ngram viewer.
But in answer to your question,
I think it varies by
culture, and it varies by time
because puns ebb and flow in
popularity.
And--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
puns are unpopular
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHN POLLACK: I can't comment
on the popularity of puns in
most of the world.
I will say this.
Every major language group in
the world has puns in it, even
Pitjantjatjara, which is a
language in the Australian
Outback, has puns in it.
And with so many T's and J's,
that's a challenge.
But it's amazing.
They're everywhere.
So I would say that they're
popular it at least in every
major language family.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How was Clinton at
punning without his writers?
He certainly plays with
meaning plenty.
JOHN POLLACK: Yeah.
Bill Clinton is great
with language.
And I can say that my arrival at
the White House had little
impact on his speaking
ability.
It was great before I got there,
and it's great now.
I did send him a copy of "The
Pun Also Rises." and he wrote
me a letter back with
a pun in it.
And he said he was glad to see
that the world pun champion
had another title.
So I he can hold his own.
Any last questions?
We've got one more, here.
AUDIENCE: I'm introducing
my four-year-old son to
"Animaniacs"--
sort of a high point for puns
in my entertainment.
And he really struggles
with it.
And he just misses
half the meaning.
Do you feel that puns are unfair
to those with limited
language or English as
a second language?
Is that maybe part
of the reason
they're looked down upon?
JOHN POLLACK: I think
that puns are good
for learning language.
And I would say that if you
look at riddles and
knock-knock jokes, which are
some of the earliest types of
humor that kids learn,
those are almost
always driven by puns.
In fact, like, what's black and
white and read all over?
The newspaper.
That's been bouncing around
since the middle of the 1800s.
And so I would say
push the puns.
The puns are great.
The whole idea is that
I think one of the
problems in our society--
and I certainly suffered from
this in my early schooling--
is that apart from watching
"Conjunction Junction," what's
your function, grammar and
language is seen as dry and
inflexible instead of an
incredibly elastic, playful
putty with which you can
do virtually anything.
And so I would say puns are an
important learning tool to
look beyond the surface of what
somebody means and what
do they really mean.
How do you bring in context?
What analogies are triggered?
And so good for you for
introducing your son to that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN POLLACK: Well, if there
are no more questions, I
really want to thank you very
much for having me.
It's an honor to be at Google.
And I appreciate your
warm welcome.
And pun with pride.